Yeah. So, uh, today we begin kind of the
the second part of the class
specifically. Up until last week, we
were focused on the, uh, bottom half of
our usual road map. Specifically, where
we focused on methods for optimal
control. So if uh if you recall we
started our discussion through openloop
methods and namely through the lens of
indirect and direct methods where the
goal was to compute an optimal
trajectory uh from a given initial
condition. Uh we then you know this is
great because they are fast and reliable
but they are specific to the given
initial condition where we are in. uh we
then moved to towards the the closed
loop section uh namely through dynamic
programming and Hamilton Jakomi Bellman
or Jaconi Isax equations where there the
focus was on computing an optimal
control policy that is a function that
maps states to optimal controls and we
saw how this was definitely more
powerful at least in principle compared
to the open loop framework because it
gives us a rule of how to behave uh
independently on the state in which
we're in But at the same time this came
with uh important kind of uh unimportant
computational expense. And so last week
we focused on MPC or model predictive
control which is basically a framework
which tries to gets the best of these
two approaches namely achieve the
performance of closed loop methods
through the recursive solution of
openloop optimal control problems.
Underlying all of these methods was the
assumptions that we knew how the
dynamics behaved. So we always knew that
we had a good representation of our
dynamics which came from maybe an
analytical expression or a differential
equation that represents our our
dynamics. And so in the second part of
this course we kind of relax this
assumptions and we move into the
learning based setting where we assume
we do not know uh in advance the
dynamics of our models. Um
yes
and so specifically for today we will be
first of all transitioning into the
learning base setup uh giving uh a rough
idea of the kind of topics we'll be
discussing and then we will be
approaching specifically the top left
part of the quadrant which relates with
more classical ways of dealing with uh
with learning um uh dealing with
learning specifically regarding uh
system identification and adaptive
control and we'll see two example of
adaptive controls namely MRACH or model
reference adaptive control or MayAK
model identification adaptive control
and as a general uh setting. So remember
the the framework the the setting we are
in. So specifically we look at
controlling some system through the
definition of a controller or a
controller. Um and in order to control
the system, we may be measuring we have
having some sensors which measure the
output of our system. And we might want
to compare these the measurements that
come from our sensor with some reference
which we have in mind that is an ideal
behavior of our system that we would
want it to um to execute. Um and this
will lead the construction of our
controller. And so we have this feedback
loop which which happens kind of in in
closed loop.
However, the question is what happens in
the moment where we have some
uncertainty or some unmodled effects in
how the system behaves. And so this is
exactly the setting in which we'll be uh
working on today and for the rest of
this class.
And so fundamentally uh so when looking
at dealing with this kind of uncertainty
that could be present in our in our
system, how can we handle this? And so
kind of a simple approach uh could be
that in many cases uncertainties may
have only a small effect. So for
example, consider we're trying to fly a
drone and we might have some unmodled
wind effects which are still pretty
small. And so in this case perhaps uh
kind of we don't really need to do
anything too sophisticated about dealing
with this uncertainty, but having a
feedback controller uh maybe may be just
enough to compensate for this amount of
effects. And so this could be as simple
as we have some reference trajectory for
our drone that we want to follow. Uh and
we might want to build a sort of
feedback controller that tracks this
reference trajectory for example through
P control. But again we're in the system
where we might have some unmodled
effects. If these are pretty small then
maybe feedback control is good enough.
A second approach is we could try to be
a little bit more sophisticated and
going into for example robust control
approaches. So we discussed or uh last
week or a couple weeks back if you
remember kind of
uh
minmax formulation where
our goal was to maximize some
measure of reward
which had the the a form of of this type
accord maximize uh with respect to our
controls u and we were assuming there
was some
distribution gamma set of distributions
gamma uh which were basically playing
the role of the adversary. So
essentially modeling the worst case
possible disturbance that could affect
my system. And in class we were looking
at this you know relatively sadistic
example of the homicidal chauffeur. uh
but uh this is if you if we see this
from the perspective of dealing with
uncertainty we it is as if we're saying
we have a system with some uncertainty
which we are not aware of things we
cannot model and so let us be robust
with respect to this uncertainty by
reasoning in the with respect to the
worst case scenario possible and so of
course this is on one hand great but it
could come with behavior that is
potentially too uh uh too defensive and
a little bit too conservative.
But again, this is a valid second high
level strategy of of approaches.
The third one, which is also the one
we'll be specifically focusing on today
and for the remaining weeks, is the one
where we have some uncertainty and we
take into consideration the fact that we
we can collect examples of um behavior
and state transitions in our
environment. So again, consider the case
where we have our drone flying uh flying
to accomplish some task. We might be
storing logs of previous flights in
order to observe these state transitions
and use those to learn from data an
approximate model of our dynamics.
And so this is exactly the the setting
we'll be uh working with. But I think
this is a nice kind of frame uh mental
model to have in the sense that whenever
we have some uncertainty, we might be
good enough with some feedback that in
order to correct for a model effects, we
might want to be extremely um
conservative and reason about worst case
scenario possible. Or we could use
datadriven approaches that leverage
pre-collected state transitions
observations in order to learn an
approximate model of our dynamics.
Any
questions on these high and high level
and macro categories of of methods?
Okay.
And so in the moment we zoom in our
third of these macrocategories that is
datadriven methods kind of the question
that comes to mind is okay we say we
want to learn something uh but what can
we learn and at a high level I would say
that different methods for learning
based control typically divide
themselves across two uh main families
of approaches. In the first one, we want
to use measurements or collected
episodes or transitions in order to
directly improve the controller.
On the other hand, we might want to use
these measurements to learn an
approximate model of our dynamics and
then use this model to approve the
controller. So you see that in the
second of these two families, we have
this intermediate objective which is uh
kind of system identification in a way
um which is then a proxy to improve our
overall controller.
And so the types of methods that we will
see today and for the rest of this class
kind of loosely fall within these two uh
buckets. And so today we'll be focusing
at uh direct adaptive control and
indirect adaptive control as well as
system identification. But in the coming
weeks we'll also focus on imitation
learning as well as model free and model
based uh reinforcement learning.
Okay. And so
as a second question that comes to mind
would be then uh kind of how how does
learning actually happen and
specifically there are three I would say
prototypical cases. The first one is the
zero episodes case which is also known
as the kind of system identification
approach. And the assumption here is
that uh we have uh in some way
pre-colcted a data set of state
transitions or rollouts if you wish of
some policy controlling our system and
we might want to use this offline data
set to improve our controller. This
could be directly improving the
controller or it could be learning a
model to then improve the controller.
But what I want to stress the fact here
is that these this zero episodes case
essentially entails having some
mechanism of collecting a data set
completely offline and then we use this
data set to estimate some some
parameters or some models in order to
improve uh controller performance.
This is to be distinguished from the one
episode case where we want to have this
adaptation and learning happening
directly online as kind of while we
control the system. And I think kind of
again taking our kind of drone example
say that we have some quadrotor that is
carrying some payload of an unknown mass
m. the one episode or online adaptation
approach would essentially mean that we
have no mechanism of um kind of
estimating this mass m from previous
flights. But this is something that we
have to estimate and adapt to online
while we control the drone. And so the
goal here would be to while we are
controlling the drone estimate some
unknown parameters such as for example
the unknown mass of our of our payload.
And then a third category of approaches
is the one of the uh multiple episodes
setting and this is the classical
framework for reinforcement learning.
The idea here is that we have some
environment with which we can interact
with. Say for example um
uh we want to learn a policy that plays
chess optimally. We this is we have an
environment which is the game
environments of chess and these
environments can be reset indefinitely.
And here learning happens in between
these episodes. So we could have a
situation where we kind of spawn our
environment the beginning of the chess
game. We interact with the environment
in order to complete one episode and
then this gets reset at the beginning
and we use these repetitions of
different strategies in order to update
our uh parameters or policies depending
on what we're trying to do.
But I hope that it is clear that kind of
the point of this slide is that once we
choose that we want to learn and
approach control through learning. uh
then kind of different algorithms will
be better suited for different settings
depending on if we assume we have
collected some data set some offline
data sets beforehand or on the other
hand whether we want to control some
system and adapt to unmodel effects
directly while we are deploying and
operating our system or in the last case
the one of the multiple episodes where
we have an environment with which we
have the luxury of being able to
interact Of
course the kind of the boundaries here
are not so strict. Uh methods fall
between different categories. So for
example I would say online reinforcement
learning typically assumes we have this
environment we can reset and com and
iteratively adapt to but there are
methods that still belong to the realm
of reinforcement learning say offline
reinforcement learning which actually
fall in the zero episode case. So don't
take this too literally, but I think
typically you have these three very
specific modalities of experience which
come into play.
Any questions here?
>> Yes. The key difference between one
episode, multiple episodes is that
multiple episodes is capable of
interacting with the environment and
learning through those interactions,
right?
So I would say that also in the one
episode case you interact with the
environment. Uh in the multiple episodes
case I would say the difference is that
you have this episodic nature where you
can learn across repeated episodes. So
again I think a good example here is
chess. So if I'm trying to learn a
policy to play chess I could play an
infinite amount of games and I improve
my policy across these games. here. If
we take the same chess analogy, it will
mean that I'm trying to learn how to
play chess in during a single game.
>> Yeah.
>> Sometimes like with multiple episodes,
that's the only way you can get to other
states, right?
>> Sorry. Can can you repeat?
>> Like like if you have a policy, if you
run it once, you can only get to the
states you you like go to in that one
versus like getting to different states
with multiple
>> in the one episode case.
>> Yeah.
No, I'm asking like that's how you get
to the other states that you wouldn't
get if you don't want time through,
right?
>> Uh yeah. So in the multiple episodes
case, if you act differently in the same
environment, you would be able to
explore different parts of your state
space. If this is what you're referring
to
episodes, if you deploy a vehicle and
then take different time horizons which
do like different actions, are could
those be considered different episodes
or is that still one episode?
So,
um, are you referring to kind of an RL
like approach where I want
>> if you're trying to
dynamics of the vehicle for instance,
like would you cut up like one, I don't
know, piloted thing of like some
operation into like multiple times and
then use that as multiple episodes or is
that still one episode?
>> I see. I would probably classify this in
the zero episode case, meaning that you
have a data set of trajectories and
you're basically chunking this up in
order to build a kind of next state
prediction or a for dynamics problem. Uh
if that makes sense because you're not
really being an necessarily an agent in
collecting that data, right? So here in
the multiple episodes case, typically
your policy, your control law is
actually the one that dictates the
experience that you have. Right? Right?
In the zero episode case, you probably
don't want a neural net from scratch
kind of driving a vehicle, right?
Because this will crash for sure. But uh
in what happens in chess is that you
have very bad policies at the beginning
and then you improve over time. Yeah.
Okay.
And so given this this this broader
framework let's approach uh kind of
learning based control methods
specifically students of classical
approaches to to learning starting from
uh system identification
and the problem and the idea of system
identification is that uh for many
problems we don't have to learn online
right but we could actually have a
pipeline where we collect data set of um
previous experiments or behaviors in a
given environment or system that we care
to model and we want to use this data
set to build a datadriven model of the
dynamics.
So in this way what we can then do is
that we we can then use this um
datadriven model to essentially replace
our knowledge of the dynamics for
control. Right? Right. So the idea is
that the overall problem we want to
solve, we have a missing dynamical
model. We want to learn to approximate
this from some data ga gathered
beforehand and then use this approximate
model as a essentially proxy for then
using any control tool that we wish to
to use.
And the classical uh at least
traditionally uh methods for or tool for
system identification is linear
regression. And so I'm sure this will be
kind of repetition for uh for most of
you. Uh but let's just set the notation
straight on uh kind of learning through
uh le square minimization uh and and
linear regression in in particular.
So specifically we are describing a a
setting where we assume that we have
some uh system model
described as y = theta transpose z plus
some noise epsilon
where y is the output.
We have some inputs Z.
Theta are some parameters which we wish
to learn.
And then we assume that this process
that we wish to approximate is described
by some in inherent noise. uh actually
and the way we want to approximate the
system is through examples
which we which we collect in a data set
D which are nothing else than tupoles of
input output pairs Z Y with either goes
from one to n data points and we want to
use this data set that we collected
offline of examples of uh input output
realizations to learn to estimate an
approximate model of our of our system.
Now, typically the way we use these uh
examples is through and the way we learn
the parameters theta to approximate our
model is through the minimization of
some sort of uh performance criterion or
loss which could be kind of the the le
squares loss. So something that
essentially encodes the difference
between the true realizations and our uh
predictions
right something of this form
in the slides we have we are referring
to capital Z as
kind of the matrix of the stacked input
vectors.
which allows us to rewrite it in in
compact form as the minimization
of the squared uklidian norm.
[snorts]
Okay. And from our all our discussions
on optimization uh and numerical
optimization we know that this is a
convex function which we wish to uh
minimize. And so we know that in order
to let's go here
to find the minimum of that function we
need to set the gradient of the
objective with respect to theta equal to
zero.
Right. So this is our necessary and
necessary and sufficient condition for
for optimality
which essentially means that we want to
take the gradient of yrpose y - 2 theta
transpose zrpose y plus theta transpose
zrpose z theta.
And we want to set this to zero.
And by taking the gradient what we get
is -2 zrpose y + 2 zrppose z theta needs
to be equal to zero which essentially
leads to the solution that we have uh on
the slide
which is basically that the value of the
parameters theta that minimize our le
squares error is zrpose
the inverse of zrppose z time zrpose y.
Okay. So, not nothing too uh technically
deep or too insightful in this slide,
but just to make sure we have the the
notation in place.
Okay. So, we're saying that we want to
use uh these tools for system
identification. So, let us map this
framework into the problem that we
actually care about which is using a
linear model to approximate our system
dynamics.
And so specifically what we're saying is
that we are assuming that our system
evolves according to uh the following uh
linear
system xt + 1 = a xt plus b u t
plus some noise T
which we can rewrite essentially more
compactly as
the dotproduct between XT UT and vector
AB
plus the noise term FT
right and once we write it this way I
think it's pretty
clear to see that this is what we're
referring to as our Y.
These are our inputs Z and these will be
our parameters theta according to the
notation from the previous slide.
[snorts]
So
in practice what this means is that we
assume we have access to a data set of
previous transitions or rollouts of our
our system. So if you wish we are
assuming we have collected some
trajectories that represent possible
evolutions of our systems. These
trajectories are nothing else than uh
collections of um
kind of states and controls
over time.
And we can then use these uh
trajectories that we collected in order
to basically construct a data set
which again is uh two poles of
XT UT which are our inputs and XT + one
which will be our outputs.
right? So this is what we mean when we
say we want to learn an approximate
model of our dynamics from from data.
That is we'll have some mechanism uh to
collect examples of evolutions of the
system and we repurpose these uh
examples essentially as a as a
regression problem which maps from
current state and current control to the
next state.
Okay. Any any questions on this?
I'm sure this is probably just a
background for for you but just to make
sure we are all on the same page.
Okay. So some comments. So in practice
uh we have shown how the solution to the
our le squares optimization entails this
inverse over zranspose z. Depending on
how large our data set is, Z could be
very large. And so doing this inverse
can also be computationally quite
expensive. And so there exists a number
of uh recursive formulations or uh forms
for this optimal uh solution which
essentially
uh enable us to avoid this recursive uh
inverse uh of a potentially very large
matrix that could be extremely expensive
in practice. So this is very useful if
we have like a stream of data coming in
and we don't want to resolve this recmp
compute this image every time and of
course here we're dealing with the
discrete time formulation but there
exist equivalent also in in continuum
time.
Okay so here just a couple of um
theoretical results you might be
familiar with. So the first one is that
uh this estimator uh is actually turns
out that it is actually the best linear
unbiased estimator
um for any noise distribution that obeys
some common assumptions specifically
that the uh noise terms epsilon t are
zero mean uncorrelated and all have the
same and finite variance. So you might
be familiar this from your statistics
classes. And if the noise distribution
is gausian specifically then this
estimator that we just derived is also
known as the maximum likelihood
estimator.
Okay. So a question that we might want
to ask ourselves the moment we decide
that this is the mechanism for which we
are trying to estimate our known
parameters is what are sufficient
conditions for which our estimator theta
hat converges to the ground truth to the
known and true parameters uh theta.
So in other in other words what we're
saying is that
say we have an x-axis here which
represents kind of the data the amount
of data that we collect and we have the
y-axis here that represents our
estimator theta hat
and consider a specific value for the
ground truth value of our parameters
theta star. What we wish to know is we
could see this this process of
estimating uh theta hat is itself as a
random variable. And what we might want
to know is first of all if given more
data does this process is it centered on
the ground truth value of theta and also
how does this estimation vary the more
data we collect.
And so the reason why I'm saying that we
could see this as a realization of
random variable is because from the
definition which we just derived of our
solution, we see how our estimator theta
hat depends on the true outputs y which
is a process that depends on noise
epsilon. Right? So we defined before our
y's as theta transpose z plus some noise
epsilon. And so by just doing the
appropriate substitutions,
so here we're just replacing the
definition of y.
And by just doing re reassembling the
terms, what we get is that we can
rewrite our estimator of theta hat as
theta plus zrpose z the inverse of
zrpose zrpose times the noise epilon.
And so epsilon is indeed some uh this is
what makes kind of our estimator itself
a random variable.
And so if this is a random variable, we
might want to study the kind of
questions we are asking over here on the
behavior of our estimator through the
lens of looking at the moments of this
uh random variable. So specifically the
uh mean and coariance of of our
estimator.
Is it clear uh what we are trying to do?
Okay.
So looking at the mean first uh first of
all we simply replace our new definition
of the estimator of theta hat inside the
expectation.
uh we
since the only uh random variable here
is the noise term epsilon, we can
basically take everything out of the
expectation operator.
And we see how we can use the assumption
that our noise terms are zero mean to
basically cancel out this right term.
And so what we get is that the
expectation of our estimator is indeed
the true value of the parameters theta
which is a nice result. Right? So what
we know here is that in expectation uh
the if we keep using our estimator of
the true parameters theta we will
converge to the true value theta. So in
this case we basically proven that the
more data we collect in expectation the
more we will actually be converging to
the ground truth value of of theta.
Okay. So similarly we can look at the
coariance. So how our estimation
oscillates around the true value of
theta and we can do again some algebraic
steps. So first of all we again just
rewrite the definition of theta hat
and then we use this useful identity
that is that the coariance of ax is
equal to a coariance of x a transpose
and here specifically
uh we define a as zrpose z so the
inverse of zrpose zrpose and x as our
noise action
And so what we get is this second row
over here. And we use again kind of one
of the assumptions that we were seeing
before on how the noise uh distribution
is defined. And specifically we were
assuming if you recall from the previous
slide
that all the error the noise terms
epsilon t are uncorrelated and all have
the same finite variance. So this
essentially means that our coariance
matrix for the epsilon values is
something that only looks has zero terms
everywhere except from the diagonal
where we have the same uh the same
variance
where here we're assuming the variance
is sigma square right
which essentially means that we can do
this [snorts] substitution over
So again doing some algebraic steps I
think the bottom line is that we get an
expression of our coariance which is the
uh variance sigma squ multiplied by the
inverse of a summation terms that goes
from 1 to n of basically different
combinations of our states and and
controls.
Now from the perspective of our
estimation process, we would like the
coariance to basically go to zero the
more data we collect, right? So we want
our estimation to be more and more
centered around our uh expectation.
And so this means that in practice since
this is an inverse and so this it goes
at the denominator what we want is that
this summation from 1 to n uh you know
the more n grows this has to go to
infinity so that the overall thing goes
to zero and so what we're saying is that
first of all this is a you know neat
result again in the sense that as long
as the you know if our system operates
forever and it operates in a non-trivial
way meaning that the x's and news that
we observe are non-trivial for example
just statically stop uh stop to zero
then that summation will go to infinity
and so our coariance will go to zero
so here I meant when I refer to as
non-trivally uh um
non-trivally operating the system what I
meant is that I refer to this
characteristic that is known as
persistent excitation which essentially
encodes this idea that we have to
continuously probe the system in in
meaningful ways. And if we do so then uh
to the limit of n that goes to infinity
also our estimator will be um exactly
around the true value of theta.
Okay. Any any questions here?
Yes. Oh, sorry. Uh I was wondering is
there an intuition on why this is
invertible enough to
>> sorry
>> like is there an intuition why this is
portable enough to like what
>> no sorry so there is here we're kind of
simplifying the the treatment there is
some uh you know I can definitely refer
you to the complete derivations that
basically uh will tell us when this is
invertible but this is just as a frame
of reference kind of uh considering that
our goal here is system dynamics uh and
estimating these true parameters theta.
I was just kind of
uh fasttracking to the overall result
saying that if we use linear models to
estimate our dynamical systems and we
use this estimator for theta then we get
something that is unbiased and that
under some regularity conditions uh
basically also converges with with zero
coariance if that makes sense. So there
are some regularity conditions that that
I'm happy to uh refer you to.
>> No. Yeah.
Okay.
And so in practice kind of system
identification kind of leads to a number
of questions, right? So we're describing
this overall framework or paradigm where
we want to essentially approximate uh
the system dynamics through by learning
from data. And so some questions that
could emerge is what if we have a data
budget? So how much data is required to
learn the model or how can we even
quantify what good means uh in terms of
uh parameter estimation? And
interestingly kind of so we're we did
all of these analysis from the
perspective of you know a statistician
wanting to analyze the performance or
the behavior of an estimator of our
parameters. But in reality what we care
about is control performance. Right? So
uh we do not really care too much about
model accuracy. What we care about is
that we get a better controller out of
this process. And so again just to make
a a visual
um a visual discussion here. So consider
the case where we have a very extreme
case where
we have our depending on some parameter
theta which we uh don't really know the
exact value of. Depending on the
parameter theta our control law would
vary wildly. So say that if theta is
negative we would have one specific
control that we have to take and if
theta is positive we would have a
different control that we have to take.
So a very kind of step-wise control
function depending on on theta and say
that the ground truth value of theta is
uh over here. Now
consider these two different estimates
for specifically theta 1 and theta hat 2
for that same uh parameter theta. Of
course, kind of the one on the left is
from a purely statistical point of view
or at least you know distance based here
is worse right because it's further off
but from the perspective of control
since we are on the right side of the
sign this would actually lead to the
controller having better performance
right so of course this is a extreme
case and completely pictorial but this
is exactly the intuition that I that I'm
referring
And in a way this is one of the the main
kind of downsides or bottlenecks of uh
these uh system identification
approaches because we are introducing
this intermediate objective that is
model estimation which is not
necessarily aligned with uh controller
performance.
Okay. Some other question is so we we
are assuming we have access to a data
set how do we collect this data set um
what if we are learning while we collect
the data set or what if we have some
safety considerations that have to be
done while we collect the the data set.
Uh of course we need to take this into
account because we would be operating in
a system with only partial knowledge of
what the system is and so we might want
to be more more conservative.
And lastly here we are assuming we are
doing everything under this linear
assumption. So we have a ground truth
linear model and we are trying to
estimate the parameters of a linear
model. So the family of models actually
matches when in reality we don't really
know what how the system behaves
sometimes right and so there's an entire
discussion on is our family of models
that we're trying to estimate expressive
enough to include the dynamics that we
actually wish to learn. And so there's a
trade-off between how much data we have,
what is the expressivity of the model we
want to learn and so forth.
Okay, any questions on system
identification before we move on to
adaptive control.
I mean, I guess the the main idea here
is pretty simple, right? So we want to
estimate a model from data and then use
this potentially to improve our
controller uh later on.
Okay. But so let's move to adaptive
control.
And if system identification was
essentially lying into this zero
episodes setting where we had this data
and we wanted to use this data to
estimate a model of our dynamics.
adaptive control fall falls into this
one episode uh setting whereby we want
to improve our control essentially
through online adaptation uh in in real
time as we operate the system. And so
this can be done again as we were saying
before by either directly improving the
controller or by first learning a model
and then using this model to improve the
controller. And this is what
differentiates between model reference
adaptive control which essentially falls
in the first category where as we will
see we're directly improving the
controller or model identification
adaptive control. So notice
identification also in the in the name
which falls under the second category
where we are first estimating a model
and then using this to improve the
controller performance.
And I would say that kind of literature
in adaptive control it's uh pretty
traditional. So it dates back to uh a
number of years ago. And I would say
that in general the classical setting is
that it does not consider the optimal
adaptive control setting whereby by
optimal I mean we are not necessarily
optimizing for some performance metric
or cost but we are but I would say that
adaptive control strategies are
typically focusing on proving the
stability of the coupled system which
entails the the coupling of the
controller the adaptive component and
the system dynamics. So how we will see
is that we won't be necessarily
optimizing for some performance metric.
So minimization of some cost function
but we will be studying the stability of
the coupled closed loop dynamics that
emerge from the definition of a specific
controller which we have to come up with
of an adaptive component that is how we
adapt the controller based on experience
which we have to decide and the system
dynamics.
Okay. And so as a brief uh recap and
detour kind of the tool we are using
throughout this class to analyze
stability is the one of leapon of
stability and specifically as we
discussed uh last week we defined the
leapon of theorem as follows. So we're
given an autonomous system x dot f ofx.
Note that we can easily represent kind
of system that are controlled through
some policy X as an autonomous system
whereby we are directly encoding the
effect of our control as a function of
the state P of X.
So we're given an autonomous system and
we have an equilibrium point XAR such
that the dynamics F at XAR are equal to
zero. So this is an equilibrium point
for our system. So we last time we
introduced leapon of stability as this
you know we we saw it from a very
pragmatic lens as this tool that enables
us to derive uh stability properties of
of the system
and we did this from the perspective of
according to the leapon of theorem for
global stability
if there exists a function that
satisfies some uh characteristics which
we'll see briefly then this equilibrium
is globally asymtoically stable. I think
last week we only discussed the local
versions of this. So we're not really
looking at the global stability but we
are reinforcing this uh today and
specifically the conditions is that uh
we need to find this leapon function v
which respects these three conditions.
The first one is that v of x so it has
to be the function v has to be positive
for all x that are not the equilibrium
point and zero at the equilibrium point.
The derivative v dot of x has to be
negative for all points that are not the
equilibrium. And the third uh property
uh and the third condition that we have
to respect which is the one we are using
to strengthen our conditions for global
stability. Uh and this is also known as
radial unboundedness is that as the norm
of x grows to infinity also the value of
the function grows to infinity.
So
visually what we're saying is that we
have a system of in x1 x2
um the aono function is something that
is like ball shaped
and that following the dynamics of the
system it essentially dissipates energy
and and reaches the equilibrium point
All right. So this is positive
everywhere except at the equilibrium
where it's zero. And the third condition
essentially says that this keeps growing
the more we go further out.
And we discussed as this was essentially
an extremely useful way of approaching
the stability property because we don't
have to um integrate our dynamics or
solve these for every possible
conditions but we just have to define a
function that respects these properties
and we can draw conclusions about the
stability of the system.
Okay.
Any any questions here? This is mostly
repetition but any questions on uh so
far.
Okay.
So what we will be doing um going
forward is that we'll be using this
leaponov stability theorem to prove
stability of uh kind of coupled system
dynamics controller and adaptive
component mechanisms. And so here we
take a little step back. We open this
parenthesis where we show exactly what
we mean by doing these leaponov
stability analysis on a system that
doesn't really entail control at all but
just to show you how we do uh the
stability analysis which we will then be
doing for the purpose of adaptive
control.
Okay.
So let me
make some room here.
Okay. And so let's consider the system
um composed of a mass spring spring
damper system where we have some mass m
on which we apply some force F. Uh we
have a spring uh K and we have a damper
uh D.
We want to prove the stability of this
system to the um zero uh point
specifically zero position and zero uh
velocity and to do this we will assume
and we'll consider that the energy of
the system is our candidate leapona
function.
So the system is described by an energy
function E of X X dot which is 12 K X
dot + 12 M
X dot squared.
Uh so essentially a combination of
potential and kinetic energy. And so
what we want to do is given a candidate
leap upon a function for our system, we
want to check those three properties
that we were describing in the previous
slide.
So in this case uh condition one and
condition three are easily derivable by
inspection. So we can see how uh this
energy function is positive for all x
and x dot uh unless these are equal to
zero. So our equilibrium point [snorts]
and we can see that as x grows also our
energy function uh grows. And so we'll
focus on our analysis on proving the
second of the three uh conditions that
is that the derivative of our function
in this case the energy function is
negative for all points that are not the
equilibrium.
So let us let us do this. So let's
compute the derivative of the energy
function E of X X dot which is equal to
K X X dot plus M X dot X dot.
[snorts] Here we can use the fact that
from our system dynamics that we know
that mx dot is equal to negative
dx dot + kx
to essentially rewrite this as k x dot
minus x dot *
dx dot + kx X
from which we know that these two cancel
out. And so we get essentially the
result that we have on the slide that is
negatived x dot squ
which indeed verifies our uh second
property because this is indeed always
negative besides from the equilibrium
point.
Okay. So this is indeed the what we mean
by performing a stability analysis
through leapon of theorems.
Okay. So let us now move to uh what we
actually care about which is adaptive
control uh techniques. And so
specifically let us start from model
reference adaptive control.
So in model reference adaptive control
we essentially will be defining four key
elements or parts. So the first one will
be a plant containing unknown
parameters. So the plant here is a very
specific word but just let's consider
the system. Uh so this is the system
where we have some unknown parameters.
We will be defining a reference model
which essentially compactly specified
the desired output that we would want to
have from our system.
In a way the reference model can be seen
as an alternative way to specify
performance. Right? So we're not really
measuring performance through the lens
of a metric or objective function that
we wish to optimize but we wish perform
we um measure performance from the
perspective of measuring distance with
respect to a reference signal.
The third element is that we will have a
feedback control law that contains some
adjustable parameters. So we will be
coming up with a control mechanism or
control policy which depends on some
parameters which are adjustable
and in particular we will be adjusting
these parameters according to an
adaptation mechanisms uh which we will
be you know tasked with coming up with.
Any question on the on the setting?
Okay, great.
Okay, so now we'll be going through an
example of the kind of analysis that
we're doing we we might be doing on um
in adaptive uh control. We'll be first
of all setting up the stage in a setting
where everything is known. So we'll be
just doing the analysis when we actually
don't have unknown parameters and
adaptation mechanisms and then we will
be taking that same example but now
adding this adjusting uh component and
repeating the analysis.
Okay. But as a
frame of reference,
remember that in adaptive control, we
care about measuring the stability of
the coupled u system controller
adaptation mechanism um system, right?
So this coupled system and so in general
we will be defining
our four ingredients. So we'll have a
system which might have some
unknown
parameters.
Uh in this case we consider a double
integrator system. So for us the system
will be mx dot= u.
We said before that we want to measure
performance as distance with respect to
our reference uh output that we wish to
have from our system. And specifically
for us the reference will be described
as
through an uh fictitious variable which
we introduce X subm which represents the
uh essentially the the the version of
our state X which we uh which we create
this kind of fictitious model. um
in order to uh represent it. So we
assume we have uh someone giving us uh
positioning command RT and we
come up with this ideal response of the
controlled uh mass uh which we assume
evolves according to this differential
equation. So we're introducing this
fictitious XM X subm and we hypothesize
that our system will evolve according to
this reference model. So X subm stands
for uh model.
[snorts]
So specifically our reference will be X
dot XM dot plus KD
XM dot plus KP XM
equals K R of T
[snorts]
right so X of M will be our ideal output
uh K the various Ks here are just gains
we can choose as a system designer and
we assume that R is a uh positioning
command that is given to us.
[snorts]
Okay.
So now we assume that the mass is known
exactly and
we can basically state the fact that if
the mass is known exactly we know that
we can achieve perfect tracking of our
reference uh model through that
controller.
So the controller specifically is that u
is equal to m * xm dot minus 2 lambda
x dot minus lambda squar xilda
where we are denoting as xilda
as the difference between the output of
the acro system and the reference the
ideal output that we would want from the
system. So if you want the the tracking
error
right. So you see here as we are
building the different ingredients of
our adaptive control uh pipeline
and you know you might wonder like where
is
any of this coming from right? The point
is that if we were actually having to
design this system we would be tasked
with designing these things ourselves.
So we would be having to uh we would
have to come up with a reference signal
which we think is appropriate for our
system. We would have to come up with a
control law which uh controls our system
which again we think is appropriate. Uh
but the purpose of this is that we are
assuming that someone gives all of these
elements to us and we are showing the
kind of stability analysis uh that
follows once we have these ingredients.
In reality, there is obviously an
iterative component where maybe we have
a system, we try out a specific type of
reference model, we see how it works,
and then maybe this doesn't we're not
really able to prove stability and we
keep iterating on this.
But for the purpose of this stability
analysis, this is the kind of setting
we're in, right? So we have a system we
define the reference uh
uh a reference that we wish to track and
we have a control law which um which
exponentially converges uh to the zero
tracking error. So to show that this is
a controller that basically converges to
zero tracking error we have to derive
the closed loop dynamics of this
combined system.
Is it clear what we are trying to do?
Okay.
[snorts]
So let us start from our system
dynamics. So m MX dot equals U.
So we have just defined u according to
this controller. And so we can basically
replace this as m
x dot mus
2 lambda x tilda dot minus lambda 2 xa
which we can rewrite as m *
X dot minus XM dot + 2 lambda X tilda
dot plus lambda squar X tilda
just to be equal to zero. So we just
brought uh this term on the other side.
Now from our definitions we know that
this is
xilda double dot
[snorts]
and so we see that we can essentially
discard m because this has be to be
equal to zero. And so if we solve this
uh OD, the solution of the OD is
actually that [snorts] x tilda t is
equal to
c 0 + c1 t * e to the lambda t.
Right?
Now we know that lambda lambda is a gain
which we choose and this gain is
positive right. So we know that lambda
here is is positive.
So what we can say is that as
t goes to infinity
then this
so x tilda t goes to zero
right
but what does this tell us about uh
tracking error?
Yes.
Yes. Exactly. So we defined Xilda as the
tracking error itself, right? So we
defined it as X - XM and we know that
this goes to zero.
[snorts]
Okay. So this was basically you know we
introduced the overall setting. We
hypothesized the mass m was known and we
basically said that this control law was
you know the controller that guaranteed
convergence to uh zero tracking error
and we have motivated it by this
analysis over here. Now we go into the
setting that we actually care about
which is the one where we assume that
the mass is not known exactly right. So
here
we assume that everything uh basically
stays the same but now we have we are in
the slightly more realistic setting
where the mass is not known and so we
will have an estimate for the mass mhat.
Okay.
So now let us once again derive the
closed loop uh dynamics of this combined
system.
Okay. And to do this let us do some um
definitions just for notational
compactness. So we'll define s as x
tilda dot plus lambda x tilda.
We'll define new as x m dot - 2 lambda x
dot minus lambda^ 2 xtilda.
And we will define m tilda as the
estimation error basically mhat minus m.
[snorts]
So given these definitions
let us essentially do the exact same
analysis we did over here. Right? So we
we will derive the closed loop dynamics
of this of this combined uh system.
So we start once again from our dynamics
mx dot equals u.
We know what u is because this is
something we defined.
But this time u is a function of the
unknown mass mhat. Right?
So, mhat
uh times x m dot
minus 2 lambda x dot x dot minus lambda
squar x tilda.
This is new,
right?
And so we get m tilda plus mn
right where basically here we're using
the fact that um mhat is equal to m
tilda plus m
from the way we defined um m tilda.
And so this leads to our closed loop
dynamics defined as m x * x dot minus
new
m tilda new
which we can expand as m *
X dot minus X M dot + 2 lambda X tilda
dot plus lambda^ 2 XA
equals
M T
where this is X dot
And so we basically get what we have on
the slide. So we have m
* s dot + lambda s
= m tilda.
[snorts]
Right? So nothing too deep here. just
some algebraic manipulations. But here
we are again defining this coupled
system and we are computing the closed
loop dynamics of this coupled system.
Okay. So now what we want to do is um
considering a specific way of adjusting
our estimate mhat. So remember that we
are interested in doing these
adaptations and so we need an adaptive
component in the picture
and specifically we assume that we will
be adjusting our estimate M hat
as according to this law that is mhat
dot is equal to negative gamma new s
where gamma is again u which we So an
adaptation gain it has to be positive,
right? Okay. So basically now we have
all of the ingredients to perform our
stability analysis through leaponov. So
what we're going to do is we will be
considering this candidate leapono
function and we will use this to
basically verify that the system is
globally asintotically stable to an
equilibrium point
and we'll study what this equilibrium
point means essentially.
Okay. So we have this candidate
function defined as uh 12 * ms^ squar +
1 / gamma
m tilda^ 2.
Remember that according to our leapon of
analysis, we have to check for our three
properties
um
which are again these ones here on the
slide. So once again the first one and
the third one are easy to prove and I'll
leave this uh up to you guys and so
we'll focus on the second one that is
that the
uh derivative of this leap of function v
dot has to be negative for all points
that are not the equilibrium
and so we'll be computing the derivative
v dot which is equal to ms s dot + one
over gamma
milda
mtilda dot.
So here we use the fact that m tilda as
we defined it is equal to mhat minus m.
But become m because m is a fixed mass
so it's a constant. From this we can say
that m tilda dot is equal m dot
right.
Yeah.
Okay.
And so what we get is ms uh * s dot
uh + 1 / gamma
m tilda * mhat dot
which is equal to ms s dot minus 1 /
gamma
m tilda
gamma new s
right where here we just used basically
the fact that M uh hat dot is equal to
negative gamma
uh no s according to how we defined the
adaptation component
which essentially leads to the fact that
the derivative of our leapon function B
dot is equal = to s * ms dot minus m
tilda
where this is - m
lambda S and so we basically get the
result on the slide, right? So we know
that
uh we can write here.
Yes. So minus lambda m^
squ right
which basically uh
uh confirms the the second validates the
second property specifically as a
function of uh s in this case. And so
what this is saying is that since we are
have been done this jacon of stab
stability uh for given this candidate
function what we can say is that
um
we can say that s goes to zero because
we are considering this as our
candidate equilibrium point. So s goes
to zero and so
remember how we defined s which is um x
tilda dot plus lambda x tilda.
What we're basically saying is that we
have shown that this quantity goes to
zero
which means that x
which means that x uh tilda dot is equal
to negative x lambda x
where lambda is positive, right? So
remember that lambda is positive. And so
we've shown that s goes to zero. And so
this means that x tilda dot converges to
uh tends to this. And so visually what
we're seeing is that our system
if we were to express it in a plot as a
function of x tilda and x tilda dot is
something that converges to the line x
tilda dot equals negative lambda x
tilda.
Right? So it's something that
as t goes to infinity converges to this
line
and specifically
once it's on the line if um x tilda is
negative the derivative of xilda will be
positive
and so it will tend to grow. On the
other hand, if x tilda is positive, the
derivative will be negative. So it will
tend to decrease.
And so we have shown that the system
will essentially be converging to this
line. And once on this line, it will be
going to zero.
[snorts]
Why do we care about this? is because if
x tilda goes to zero, we know that x
tilda is our tracking error essentially
and so x minus xm also goes to zero.
>> Yes.
Sorry.
>> So here we were using the tool of leapon
of stability to essentially prove uh
well stability of the system to an
equilibrium point. Specifically this uh
leapono candidate leapono function
uh is defined as as such which is
basically
a function of of s in this case here.
And so we have verified
explicitly the second of the three
properties. But the other three are more
easily shown by even just by by
inspection. And we know that if um
candidate the function satisfies these
three properties, it shows that the
system will be globally and
asintotically stable to uh the
equilibrium point. um which in this case
for us was showing that
>> [snorts]
>> uh the system would essentially be
globally asotically converging to uh s
going to zero and we show then the this
analysis whereby if s is going to zero
then the tracking error will also be be
going to zero. So we're this is in a way
like a onetoone mapping and application
of the leapon of stability theorem if
that makes sense.
Yes,
>> in this case with unknown mass and the
previous case with known mass is prove
convergence like stability but not
actually computing gamma or computing
what I've done.
>> No, so indeed let me um take a step
back. So specifically we you know the
the general setting we're working with
is we are introducing adaptive control
and we mentioned that classically
adaptive control is instantiated as
having to come up with um a coupled
system of different ingredients namely a
system the controller and an adaptation
mechanism of some adjustable parameters.
And the entire problem will be posited
as we want to derive the and prove the
stability of this coupled system. Right?
So specifically what we have shown
before is that we we basically con built
constructed towards this example by
first introducing the case where M was
known and we just proved the stability
of that overall system. Um now we are
introducing adjustable uh an adaptation
mechanism in order to adjust our
estimate of M and these adaptation
mechanisms rely on some gains that we uh
are introducing in practice we would
have to tune this gain that kind of now
to answer your your questions more
directly um so I'm aware that this I
would say this analysis can be can feel
you know some somewhat intricate and
complex in the sense that we are
introducing a lot of functions which is
kind of unclear where it comes from.
We're introducing a control law which is
also unclear where it comes from and
same thing for the reference. The
reality is that if we were to you know
study this explicitly this would be an
extremely case specific uh discussion
and so I think for the purpose of this
class not very meaningful. So the
reality is that whenever we have a
system and we wish to apply adaptive
control for the system, we will have to
be doing some studies and you know
analysis on ways of deriving all of
these components, deriving the
reference, deriving the control law,
deciding how I want to adapt my
adjustable parameters and also deriving
a candidate Japan function. So, a lot to
to take in. But then kind of what we
decided to to focus on for the purpose
of this class is showing that once we
have all of these ingredients, what are
the stability analysis that that come uh
as a as a result?
>> Yes.
>> This analysis with hinged on that
particularly function, right? Yes.
>> Yeah. This is the the point where we are
completely kind of fasttracking. The
reality is that you know if you have an
interesting system and you derive a
leapon function and you show that the
system is stable, you write a paper
about it and you're you're happy about
it. So so this is you know something
where it's extremely case dependent. Uh
we won't go into it. I think there are a
number of references that I'm uh
actually I think the next slides is
exactly on this. So I definitely advise
you to look into this reference over
here to basically see the if you wish
the forward direction of this uh
discussion. So until now we've basically
been assuming that either us you know a
previous version of us or someone
incredibly smart is giving us all of
these things and we just analyze it. But
in practice we have to come up with it.
All right so I'm out of time so I'll
conclude the discussion of Mayak next
time and see you see on Wednesday.